our very first time this has ever
happened a millionaire drove in to be in
the lobby of Ramsay Solutions to do this
interview right here in our lobby
welcome Julie how are you oh I am
wonderful Dave every day above ground is
a good day I hear ya and you're from
where Cincinnati Ohio Wow okay so for
five hour drive I guess not bad yeah
well thank you for coming in so what is
your net worth four point three million
way to go good job and what is that
what's the breakdown of that what's it
invested in well the point three is my
house the rest of it is in the stock
market primarily mutual funds that does
include both my husband and my IRA and
each of us have over a million our
individual IRAs and those are Roth IRAs
by the way so the taxes are paid very
nice very nice and what are your age I'm
59 okay
and how much of the 4.3 million was
inherited you heard me just talk about
that I'm from a poor family
zero-zero oh you inherited was the
desire to not be broke that's right so
what was the range of your household
income through your working life well I
have to break this down to the first
million and then thereafter okay I was a
millionaire by the time I was 37 okay
and every time I say I I really mean to
include my husband Mark he couldn't be
here today okay
but it should be weed but since I'm the
person talking I'm saying I that's okay
we when we had our first million we were
millionaires by the time we 437 how did
you do that frankly Dave unfortunately
this was before the baby steps were out
there and so we had to figure it out
ourselves
mm-hmm we read a lot but also we came
down to a very simple strategy
mm-hm we had two incomes we lived on one
and we paid off our debts with the other
and then once we paid off the debt then
we started investing sounds like our
plan that's what we did very good so
what was your income during those years
it was
4250 k Wow yep and that's how you got
the first million that's how I got the
first million and they say the second
one's easier was it the second one is
really easy my husband and I both
switched careers
uh-huh we went to IT I was an Account
Manager sales and IT recruiting and he
moved over to actually he's in big data
now mm-hmm so so our incomes went up
it's been anywhere from 100k some every
once in a while we'll have a great year
one year we had about 300 but that's you
know abnormal for us and what's your
degrees in well I have a degree in
chemical engineering mm-hmm and then my
husband has a marketing degree okay and
GPAs mine was around three and my
husband's was similar okay all right and
how much of the four point three million
is there because you borrowed money to
create wealth none okay
and what part is giving played in your
your financial plan through these years
Oh Dave I have to tell you this is
something and you have to bear with me
because I get choked up about giving
because this is the best part of being
wealthy my husband and I both believe
that the Lord loves all his creation and
because of that we decided that we were
going to set up avenues to help people
and we were going to set up avenues to
help animals and most of our giving for
people is through the church we've also
been able to set up scholarship funds at
our respective high schools
Wow those were on our bucket lists
that's what both of us wanted very cool
and for animals my husband and I have
both been volunteers at this no-kill
Animal Shelter
it's regional one his paws it's in
Monroe Ohio we've been volunteers in one
capacity or another for over 25 years we
built a new shelter
we had a mortgage and frankly I'm scared
to death of mortgages mm-hm and so we
have been able to issue a personal
challenge in the amount of a quarter of
a million dollars that we are meeting
donations
up to that amount one-to-one yes it'll
pay off their mortgage good for you
that's fun
so anyway matching giving leveraging
you're giving their and the matching
idea that's a great idea very well done
so how many brand-new cars before you
were 37 before your first million did
you buy none zero
we have beaters okay very cool and
what's your all's reading habits look
like in a month many books you read oh
my goodness my husband and I are both
avid readers I would say both of us read
six to eight books a month Wow yeah
you're voracious yes we are both of us
that's why I feel I feel shamed right
now I thought I read a lot Wow very cool
very cool and how much of the four point
three million did you all steal
[Laughter]
I couldn't resist I'm sorry so your
message to the 25 year old version of
you guys can this still be done and what
should they do well I have two messages
one is to the 25 year old version and I
would say it's incredibly easy but
youyou I would recommend starting early
you know the eighth wonder of the world
is compound interest hmm and frankly it
only took us what if you put together a
paying off debt and becoming a
millionaire a total of seven years no
that's not too long in your overall
lifespan yeah but that would be my
advice to my 25 year old self but let's
say it's me talking to my 70 year old
self 7 yes my say if I were talking to
myself as an older person or 70 as a 70
year old the answer is thank you
well Dave what I would also say is it's
never too late
I have a friend who was a single mom and
she's a couple years older than me and
about ten years ago she went through a
nasty divorce has some children you know
you in that situation you're in the hole
mm-hmm she told me just this week she's
become a millionaire last years well it
can be done and the there are not
structural flaws with the economy they
keep the little men down and that stuff
that you hear it's just it is it's being
ridiculously weird and you all have been
weird and your spending patterns your
habit patterns are not normal they're
not what most people do but you have an
abnormal level of wealth and there is a
causation there there is a correlation
and a causation for those of you that
struggle with statistical analysis in
your ideologies but it really is this is
what causes it because we see this theme
all throughout our research and all
throughout these people that we talk to
Julie way to go congratulations oh thank
you Dave nice to meet you good to meet
you thank you for making the trip all
the way from Cincinnati it's a 100 or
spend time talking to you hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
you
[Music]